alexander dobrindt sagt die schulen
müssen aber sicher sein die schulen sind
sicher weil dieses virus kinder nach
allem was wir wissen in keiner weise so
betrifft wie erwachsene der weg zur
schule ist für ein kind mindestens
genauso gefährlich wie das was kind
droht wenn es an corona erkrankt die
aufgabe der politik wäre es einfach
vielleicht auch mal nicht angst zu
schüren wie wir das in den letzten
anderthalb jahren erlebt haben wie wir
es von karl lauterbach erlebt haben der
keine gelegenheit auslässt sozusagen
untergangsszenarien für all unsere
kinder zu beschwören waren immer ist nur
geht sondern die arbeit zu leisten die
ganz klar sagt alle daten sagen das ist
eine krankheit die hochaltrigen menschen
besonders betrifft die auch menschen in
unserem alter betreffen kann aber die
kinder keine wirklichen auswirkungen hat
gefährdet in den schulen sind lehrer
lehrer sollten sich impfen lassen das
ist meine meinung ich finde auch dass
das die pflicht von lehrern ist sich
impfen zu lassen wenn sie für diesen
staat arbeiten und diese aufgabe
angenommen haben aber wir sollten nicht
kindern angst machen weil ich kann es
aus persönlichem erleben immer nur
wieder sagt kinder leben inzwischen in
angst davor dass sie diesem virus zum
opfer fallen oder dass sie ihre
großeltern umbringen und beides ist
eigentlich nicht wirklich gerechtfertigt
und beides ist menschengemacht und
politik gemacht und ich finde dass eines
der beschämendsten versagen dass wir
anderthalb jahre jetzt unsere kinder in
angst und schrecken versetzt haben
obwohl es mit vernünftigem
verantwortlichen verhalten dazu keinen
eigentlich keinen grund gebe das ist so
als würde man dem kind jeden morgen auf
dem weg zur schule sagen ich habe ein
bisschen das gefühl du könntest heute
überfahren werden das ist das was wir
was wir unseren kindern gerade an tun
und es ist absolut unmenschlich
[Musik]